fabricio alvarado el líder como se hace
llamar en esta campaña presidencial es
el candidato de derecha conservadora del
recién creado partido nueva república
periodista ex diputado salmista
evangélico y polémico por su empatía con
jair bolsonaro vuelve a la contienda por
segunda vez en la elección pasada su
rechazo al matrimonio igualitario no lo
benefició esta vez no habla del tema y
se centra en otras propuestas generar
empleo reactivar la economía sin más
impuestos bajar impuestos y lograr
captar recursos mediante otras
propuestas que no sean más impuestos
lynette saborío ex vicepresidenta de la
república también arrastra la intención
de voto del partido de centroderecha
unidad social cristiana la abogada fue
directora del organismo de investigación
judicial ministra de presidencia y de
planificación le han señalado de poseer
un discurso ambiguo en esta campaña yo
creo que si hay algo que me mueve es
sentir que podemos hacer
transformaciones para lograr una
justicia social mayor jose maria
figueres de liberación nacional es el
más veterano estas elecciones ya estuvo
en la silla presidencial a finales de
los 90 este empresario de tendencia
socialdemócrata lidera las encuestas por
el legado de su padre que fue el
presidente que abolió el ejército sus
detractores le señalan una supuesta
falta de ética en casos de corrupción en
el pasado se han levantado muchos falsos
que en toda la historia de este país
nunca fiscal alguno ha llamado josé
maría figueres para cuestionarlo tan
siquiera sobre ningún caso a pesar de
que la intención de votos se centra en
tres candidatos de los 25 inscritos los
costarricenses que irán a las urnas se
inclinarán hacia un presidente que
resuelva los problemas económicos que
dejó la pandemia sin embargo más del 30
por ciento del electorado está indeciso
con las opciones a pocas horas de la
votación por lo que una segunda ronda
para abril próximo parece inminente